digamos que tenemos la siguiente función
y es igual a 5 que multiplica a 2
elevado a la t ok y ahora alguien llega
y te dice hey mira esta función está
bastante interesante pero estoy de
curioso y yo quiero el número y déjeme
cambiar de color quiero el número 1111
1111 y tengo una curiosidad de para qué
valor de t mi función lleva a tomar el
valor de 1.111 así que creo que es el
momento adecuado para que tú pausas el
vídeo y lo intente resolver por ti mismo
ahora bien si decide una pista vamos a
tener que usar la calculadora así que
por ahora pausa este vídeo e intenta
hacerlo por ti mismo
muy bien suponiendo que ya pausas del
vídeo es hora de empezar a trabajar con
este problema yo lo que quiero saber es
para que te funcione igual a 5 x 2
elevado a la t es igual a 1.111 así que
vamos a ponerlo yo lo que quiero es
saber para qué t 55 que multiplica a 2
elevado a la t ok esto es igual que mil
111 así que déjeme parando por aquí yo
lo que quiero saber es para que te esto
es igual a mi 111 de lujo así que como
cada vez que se hace algo de forma que
frye que es un poco útil pues vamos a
intentar despejar la variable para la
cual estamos intentando resolver esta
ecuación es decir lo que nosotros
necesitamos encontrar es para que te
para cuál valor de t esto es exactamente
igual que esto así que en un primer paso
lo que se me ocurre es que podemos
quitar este 5 es decir vamos a quitar
este
de este lado de esta ecuación y para
esto voy a dividir todo entre 5 voy a
dividir esta parte entre 5 y pueden
dividir también esta parte entre 5 de
tal manera que este 5 que multiplica y
este 5 que dividen se van y me va a
quedar que 2 elevado a la t esto debe de
ser igual a 1.111 entre 5 a 1.111 ok
esto dividido entre 5 o ok pero recuerda
que lo que queremos es despejar t
despejarte de esta ecuación 2 elevadoras
es igual a 1.111 entre 5 es decir lo que
necesito es despejar a la t de esta
función de exponencial y para eso vamos
a aplicar la función inversa a la
función exponencial y cuál es la función
inversa de la función exponencial pues
claro la función logaritmo es decir que
cuando nosotros tenemos a elevado a la b
esto es exactamente igual a c
bueno pues esto implica que
el logaritmo el logaritmo en base a en
base a de c esto sea exactamente igual
que b ha elevado la b igual a cero este
enunciado es equivalente que el lugar y
no en base a de c es igual a 20 o dicho
otra manera a qué potencia tenemos que
elevar a para que nos dé ser bueno pues
la respuesta es bien ha elevado a la b
es igual a cero entonces la potencia y
la que tenemos que elevar a para que nos
deseo es ver estos dos enunciados son
enunciados equivalentes perfecto bien
así que apliquemos el logaritmo en base
2 de ambos lados de esta ecuación y nos
va a quedar que el logaritmo el
logaritmo en base 2 de 2 elevada tema de
2 elevado la t esto es exactamente igual
que el logaritmo que el logaritmo
en base 2 de esto que tenemos aquí de
1.111 1111 ok esto dividido entre 5
ahora fíjate en el lado izquierdo de
esta ecuación cuánto es el logaritmo en
base 2 de 2 elevado la td2 elevado de
ate o de otra manera lo que buscamos es
a qué potencia tenemos que elevar 2 para
que nos dé 2 elevadora tema y bueno ya
me puedes decir que toda esta parte de
aquí toda la parte izquierda se puede
simplificar solamente al valor de t si
tú te preguntas a qué potencia tengo que
elevar 2 para que me dé 12 elevada temp
bueno pues la potencia stem y bueno esto
es exactamente igual que el logaritmo en
base 2 de esta expresión que tengo aquí
111 todo esto dividido en tres y ok
ahora esta es la expresión que nos va a
dar el valor de t y seguramente la
siguiente pregunta es cómo vamos a
obtener este valor de t bien como no
todas las calculadoras tienen el botón
del logaritmo en base 2 vamos a buscar
una forma alternativa para obtener este
resultado así que vamos a aplicar una de
las más poderosas propiedades de los
exponentes si nosotros tenemos el
logaritmo el logaritmo en base 2 y es
más déjenme hacerlo para una base
cualquiera nosotros nos tomamos el
logaritmo en base a de c esto lo podemos
reescribir de la siguiente manera como
el logaritmo el logaritmo en una base
cualquiera a máximo por de la base x
para verlo de una forma general el
logaritmo en base x dc que a su vez esto
está dividido entre el lugar
en base xd
y este cualquiera debe de ser el mismo
esta x debe de ser la misma y es que
esto es bastante útil porque todas las
calculadoras tienen el logaritmo que es
el logaritmo en base 10 y el logaritmo
natural que es el logaritmo en base
así que utilicemos para esta expresión
se me ocurre utilizar el logaritmo + 10
esto es exactamente lo mismo que
tomarnos el logaritmo el logaritmo en
base 10 de esta parte de aquí que es mil
111 mil 111 ok esto dividido entre 5 ya
esto lo tenemos que dividir entre el
logaritmo esto dividido entre el
logaritmo el logaritmo el logaritmo en
base 10 de la base anterior es decir el
logaritmo más de diez dedos y esto a
cuánto es igual y es momento de sacar la
calculadora así que la voy a traer por
acá y bueno yo lo que quiero hacer es
esta expresión que tengo aquí ahora tú
puedes utilizar también el logaritmo
natural en lugar del lugar en base 10 si
tú lo deseas pero bueno yo lo que quiero
es esta expresión que tengo aquí así que
vamos a ponerla con mucho cuidado el
logaritmo en base 10 de 1.111 ok esto /
/ entre 5 ok y esto a su vez estamos en
esta parte de aquí arriba lo voy a
dividir entre el logaritmo en base 10 o
el log de 2 ok y ahora cierro paréntesis
cerramos otro paréntesis y es el momento
adecuado para ver cuánto es este
resultado esto es lo mismo que ok 7.79 y
bueno para no poner todos estos
decimales aproximadamente vamos a decir
que es 7 puntos 7 9
entonces esto es aproximadamente
aproximadamente aproximadamente 7.796
aproximadamente 7.796 así que cuando te
es aproximadamente 7.796 entonces toma
el valor de 1.111